Our first investors,
I don't know if it's the first investor
because we had a few on day 1.
They were the best possible fit for us.
They shared the same culture as us,
the same beliefs.
The same approach of
starting a business.
They gave us their full support.
They really believed in the team.
Some believed in the CDO
more than in the CEO.
Some believed in the CEO
more than the CDO.
But they were there for us.
And working with them was an experience
that I will never forget.
And I owed him so much like Michael is,
I owed him to my first investors.
They validate your vision and
they say okay, you are not crazy.
We believe that you can lead a team
to execute on this crazy vision.
And when people that you appreciate say
something like that and actually put
their money where their mouth is, it's
something very special, something very
special happens when when they do it for
some people, for most people even if.